c'est le le gynécologue il est en train
non non
non
elle est super sympa allez stop pénétrer
par l'idée
on sort d'une chatte à l'oignon là
d'accord c'est le mec il a son coiffeur
qui le fait chier parce que son coiffeur
c'est ce que c'est quoi faire lui
connaît tout le monde quoi il y a pas un
mec qui connaît pas quoi et l'autre ça
le c'est le gonfle quoi il dit je
travaille avec Cyril on a mais dit je le
connais c'est moi qui lui taille sa
barbe et tout c'est moi qui ai rasé
parce qu'elle Obispo et toi mec il est
tout le monde quoi il connaît absolument
tout le monde et ils sont pas dit ça me
semble qu'un jour il revient et lui dit
bah tiens moi j'en ai une pour toi j'ai
rencontré je suis allé à Rome
j'ai rencontré le pape qui dit tu me
racontes des conneries mais dis je te
jure mon père il avait le numéro de
téléphone d'un garde suisse là-bas je
l'ai contacté m'a laissé passer je suis
arrivé jusque dans les appartements du
papa il y a un moment je l'ai vu je l'ai
d'ouvrir la porte fenêtre il saluait aux
balcon la foule sur la place
Saint-Pierre il y a même un moment je
suis mis derrière lui et ben comme ça tu
as les journalistes étaient fous quoi
tout ce tour de moi en me disant qui
êtes-vous tout ça mais dis attends tu
blagues mais dis tu as parlé avec le
Saint-Père mais dit comme je parle avec
toi
et ben écoute il m'a regardé la première
phase qui m'a dit il m'a dit c'est qui
qui t'a fait cette coupe de merde
[Applaudissements]
le mec pareil il arrive d'y jouer un
double whisky sans glace qu'il descend
il en recommande un autre 4-5 le garçon
il dit pardon de vous dire je vous vois
dégringoler les doubles whisky comme ça
vous fêtez peut-être quelque chose le
mec il dit oui vous avez peut-être tombé
pile je souhaite je fête ma première
pipe
hello tu dis première pipe mais vous
avez quel âge dit j'ai 35 ans le garçon
a dit première pipe
à 35 ans laissez-moi vous offrir un
septième whisky le mec qui dit non ça va
le le goût est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
un coup de malchance
[Applaudissements]
lui devient milliardaire et gagne à
l'Euromillions on gagne 177 millions
d'euros tu vois et il regarde sur une
revue c'est la feuilleté un truc et il
s'aperçoit que New York un hôpital avec
un très grand chirurgien ils font des
greffes de bits tu vois et ça ça reprend
et si jamais ça reprend pas tu es
remboursé tout le monde ça a l'air
d'être un truc très très sérieux il
monte dans l'avion on l'a jamais pris
l'avion de sa vie là il est en first tu
vois on vient chercher sa valise et
jamais vu ça de sa vie tu vois et il
arrive là-bas au pied d'une tour immense
c'est au 67e étage entre guillemante
deux portes s'ouvrent devant lui
avec une légère fumée blanche de carbo
tu vois la la fumée qu'on fait quand on
veut faire du froid tu sais parce que
tout est réfrigéré là-dedans évidemment
c'est un magasin en fait de beats
[Rires]
lui il a une valise qui est bourrée de
de liasse de billets de 500 balles tu
vois qui craint personne toi et il
rentre dans une première pièce et le
grand type en smoking arrive avec trois
valises trois mecs qui l'accompagnent
ils posent des valises devant lui c'est
très très solennel très chic il ouvre
première venue
et là il voit des [__] alignés
[Applaudissements]
ça c'est le modèle standard mais c'est
quand même du 24 cm
c'est imparable les gens qui ont agressé
ça c'est extraordinaire jamais un seul
rejet tous les gens ils sont ils sont au
paradis
la deuxième et où caca deuxième valise
la poche de la troisième vous le ferez
un peu de fumée qui parle il dit bah là
c'est le modèle impérial
c'est la 32 cm qui est là alors là vous
craignez plus personne que
vous le roi du pétrole il peut pas
s'empêcher de loucher ça sur la
troisième
valise chacun
[Musique]
merci monsieur
il y en a qu'une toi 42 cm il a les
livrer avec des rondelles en peau de
chameau si jamais c'est
et ben si vous êtes trop long vous
pouvez mettre des rondelles jusqu'à 10
cm soit alors là vous faites devenir
folle n'importe quel n'importe quelle
femme et là le mec il réfléchit il a le
pognon là dans la valise et lui dit
sinon
en blanc vous n'avez rien
[Rires]
oui je suis obligé d'enchaîner par la
blonde qui arrive aux urgences à la les
deux oreilles carbonisées toutes noires
dit voilà c'est à dire que quand le
téléphone a sonné j'étais en train de
repasser ah il dit oui d'accord mais
pourquoi le l'autre oreille elle est
carbonisée aussi bah dit ça c'est que
j'ai appelé le SAMU
[Rires]
un petit vieux il est sur un banc public
mais en larmes il pleure il est
inconsolable de deux autres messieurs
qui arrivent si vous arrivez monsieur
il pleure il pleure dit voilà ça va pas
en plus c'est vraiment dommage parce que
j'ai épousé il y a un an une femme de 30
ans un ancien mannequin ancienne Miss
extraordinaire une femme absolument
sublime j'ai qu'une belle maison qui est
riche et tout en plus elle aime la [__]
comme comme personne
ma journée j'ai 80 ans je caresse les
seins de l'autre et tout c'est une
merveille et je me suis dit enfin dit
vous avez une vie extraordinaire
pourquoi vous pourquoi vous pleurez
dimanche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trois campeurs à la montagne ils ont
monté leur petite tente canadienne et
sont rangées tous les trois voilà ils
dorment bien le matin je suis de gauche
il se réveille Roy il dit c'est trop
j'ai bien dormi mais toute la nuit j'ai
rêvé comme caresser le sexe
et celui de droite
parce que moi j'ai rêvé exactement la
même chose et celui du milieu dit ah
c'est ça j'ai rêvé toute la nuit que je
faisais du ski de fond
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
penché un peu
dangereusement sur le sur le côté gauche
tac et un jeune homme qui arrive
on a même Mika qui la remet bien bien
droite voilà 20 minutes après la mamie
elle se met pencher comme ça
dangereusement de l'autre côté un autre
jeune homme qui arrive hop il remet la
mamie droite tu vois c'est lequel et le
lendemain donc la famille arrive dit
alors mamie dit la literie mais vous
pouvez passer savoir j'ai jamais dormi
comme ça le chef trois étoiles il
mangeait des trucs à dire juste un petit
truc c'est con parce que ça ça gâche
tout le mec qui dit consomme mamie ça
gâche vas-y dis-moi je vais leur parler
au prix que ça coûte et ben elle dit
écoute je sais pas pourquoi mais il
m'empêche de péter
le mec est cambriole une banque avec un
masque de Mickey tu sais comme il y a
dans le cinéma il braque la caissière et
au moment où il abrac
l'élastique du masque de Mickey il pète
ah merde tu vois le masque tombe par
terre ramasse très vite il lui dit tu as
vu mon visage elle dit ben oui un petit
peu pas longtemps mais Baba deux balles
dans la tête
tu as vu mon visage je dis non alors je
vous jure moi j'ai pas vu du tout j'ai
rien vu du tout je te crois pas
retourne il y a un couple derrière lui
dis toi
salut mon visage mec dit non moi je l'ai
pas vu mais ma femme
[Applaudissements]
et triplés qui arrivent à l'école
maternelle tu vois la directrice elle se
déplace jamais eu de triplés oh des
commissions mignons regarde-moi ça
s'adresse au premier des candidates il
m'appelle Philippe madame oh Philippe tu
es trop mignon et toi moi je m'appelle
Michel c'est bien c'est bien Michel il
dit ce troisième et toi quand tu l'avais
dit je m'appelle Marco
allez vite tremblent c'est de la de la
maternelle
recule d'un pas tu en as eu peur elle
dit mais Marco quand ça se fait tu tu as
une voix de Centaure quoi enfin tes
frères par normalement j'ai une petite
voix de de 8 ans mais toi qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ben Marco il dit Monsieur on
était trois et comme ma mère avec deux
nichons j'ai été obligé de sucer mon
père
[Applaudissements]
je suis viré non
ça passe
tout un tas de conneries et il y en a il
dit moi mon chien ils veulent
on s'est raconté plein de conneries on a
bu plein de bière et tout mais ça
n'existe pas tu as pas un chien qui
veulent et dit quoi j'ai pas un chien
qui veut tu viens chez moi être montré
comment tu arrives sixième étage
il ouvre la porte là
il y a Bobby qui est là
c'est Bobby
il est vas-y baby
le chien il bouge pas toi
mais en boire une dernière mais arrête
avec ce chien le tissu en pétard après
mobile lui met un coup de pied dans le
cul dit baby
diarrête oh tu es en train de martyriser
[Rires]
mais [__]
vol jette le chien il s'écrase cinq
étages plus bas et l'autre il dit tu
vois qui est un connard
j'avais dit un chien ça vole pas et le
dit non c'est pas qu'ils veulent pas
c'est qui me
c'est mec qui croit il dit à son pote il
dit écoute j'en ai marre je crois que ma
femme est sourde tu dis ben tu sais il y
a un test à faire si tu veux vraiment
savoir si ta femme est sourde tu rentres
à la maison à peine ta franchi la porte
tu dis à autre intelligible voix tu dis
chérie qu'est-ce qu'on mange toi si elle
dit rien tu vois dans l'endroit où se
trouve ta femme la cuisine par exemple
une fois dans la cuisine tu redis très
clairement chérie qu'est-ce qu'on mange
si elle répond toujours pas tu viens
juste derrière elle dans son dos mais
tes mains comme ça ils disent
qu'on mange et là si elle te répond pas
c'est qu'elle est sourde il va et ben je
vais essayer ce soir ouvre la porte
chérie qu'est-ce qu'on mange rien la
cuisine sa femme qui est là chérie
qu'est-ce qu'on mange rien va juste
derrière elle chérie qu'est-ce qu'on
mange et la sa femme se retourne dit
pour la troisième fois des lasagnes
[Applaudissements]